[Musique]
parfois de lui donner la passe en france
de pouvoir est largement positive et
plus j'ai parlé des voix encore ce matin
dans la chambre du roi aux nouvelles
beaucoup d'honneur monsieur dans la
chambre du roi un riche bourgeois qui
veut devenir un noble une source de
moquerie pour molière lorsqu'il a écrit
le bourgeois gentilhomme ici monsieur
jourdain et les différents personnages
sont joués par des lycéens de trappes
une découverte de l'importance du
costume de costumes jfx ans après qu'on
m'a donnée consomme c'est sûr que ça ça
m'a mis plus à l'aise par rapport au
personnage
moi ça va être en mieux pal la paire est
dilatée vraiment drôle de personnage à
tout
ils ont préparé plusieurs scènes
extraites du bourgeois gentilhomme et
l'exercice étant
de le répéter une fois sans costume
blanc comme dans le cas d'une répétition
et une fois avec les costumes des
costumes là
traditionnel est économiste et
historique et de voir tout ce que ça
apportait à la fois pour le public donc
pour ceux qui observait la les
répétitions et pour les acteurs mise en
place par le centre de musique baroque
de versailles cet atelier s'inscrit dans
le projet génération du lit une
cinquantaine d'élèves ont pu se
familiariser avec l'univers de la
comédie
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'intérêt
surtout pour les costumes parce qu'ils
n'ont pas l'habitude d'un sont quand
même des costumes a l'habitude de voir
ni de toucher manipuler et surtout pas
d'enfiler et donc ils ont été
effectivement très fin très surpris et
je pense toucher parce que ça fait
partie d'un certain patrimoine dans le
cadre de génération du lit près de 1000
trappistes sont invités à participer à
ce type de découverte une action
éducative artistique et culturelle qui
va durer jusqu'en 2018
[Musique]